What does full stack AI engineering even
look like today in the serverless
environment? Let's talk about it. My
name is Brook Riio. I'm a technology
partner with thrive.com and excited to
share with you some things I've learned
about running production AI engineering
workloads in a full stack and serverless
environment. So let's dive in. The
question of 2025 is how do we deploy
zero ops resilient agentpowered user
ready apps today? How do we make it
happen to get a agentic workflows into
the hands of users as AI engineers? This
is what uh our job is. This is our goal.
Let's think about how we do this in a
modern
way. There are of course so many
options. We are uh overwhelmed with
different pieces of the infrastructure
which basically is going to need to look
like this. some type of client app, an
agent framework, an orchestration layer,
all running somehow serverlessly in the
cloud. So we don't have to fiddle with
all the details of managing ops. Of
course, each one of these options
themselves has so many options. Uh you
could be running things in Remix, Astro,
View, Spelvel, Next.js, and so many
more. For agent frameworks, um uh
there's probably a new one announced
every day. Now, we're probably hearing
more and more about new agent frameworks
like Langchain, Verscell's AI SDK,
Flowwise agents, OpenAI's agents SDK as
well, and so many
more. There are also dozens of
orchestration layers that we could be
playing with. Temporal, AWS Step
Functions, Langmith, ingest and so many
more. And of course, so many different
serverless environments to deploy to.
Lambda API gateway plus Bedrock on AWS.
Google has
Vertex. Azure has AI Studio Verscell and
dozens of other serverless cloud
environments for us to deploy to. So
many options and probably in combination
at least 42 million combinations of
these things. I don't even know what's
going to be the best. But I'm going to
tell you about my favorite because the
question AI AI engineers are asking is
how does it all work together? How do we
get the right pieces of the right layers
to actually function? Uh, and if you run
this through an LLM, you're going to get
lots of different answers. You're going
to get uh some code that maybe might
kind of work. Uh, even if you pick your
favorite stack, there's there's not
really likely to be a bunch of reference
code in the training data. Uh, and even
leveraging original docs can prove very
difficult. I put this talk together
because I struggled with this very thing
trying to make it happen uh over and
over again in a production environment
and I went through um a bunch of
different combinations and landed on my
favorite which is what I want to tell
you about today. Uh as maybe I gave it
away in the talk description but my
favorite is indeed a combination of
using Nex.js with its built-in streaming
first class server actions filebased and
nested routing in Nex.js
JS5 and a deep in integration with
Versell hosting makes this my choice for
client apps for agent frameworks. Uh
from the first day that open I open
OpenAI announced their agents SDK uh I
was all in on it. It's got native tool
calling oneshot multi- aent calls. Uh it
builtin tracing and eval hooks so you
can really get a lot of observability
out of this thing. And of course strong
backing from OpenAI. uh they're
supporting this, it's not going away,
and they allow you to interchange
models. So you're not stuck in uh their
ecosystem even if you're using their
open source agents AI SD agents SDK
framework. So uh overall then for
orchestration my choice is
ingest. Ingest uses events to trigger
things. It's you don't have to manage
JSON documents of state machines or
anything like that. Uh it works entirely
on demand. There's no worrying about
keeping your servers warmed up. Uh, it's
got automatic retry, step level
observability. You can see what's
happening step by step and where the
errors are. And a really nice one-click
integration with Verscell. So, you can
probably guess what I'm going to say.
For serverless, let's go with Verscell.
Verscell's got preview deployments with
every push. This makes continuous
deployment uh no longer a difficult
concern but an actual just integrated
part of your workflow. You can have your
whole team reviewing your latest changes
on preview branches. Uh and uh even as
you're getting that merged into main uh
Versel deploys it all for you so you can
see it functioning. It's an incredible
experience. If you haven't tried it yet,
I'm here to tell you you need to try it.
They also have a really strong edge
network, automatic CDNs, uh a bunch of
integrated database options from uh
Postgress to uh Reddus to blob storage.
And of course, since Verscell is the
company that's behind Nex.js, there's a
really strong alignment with uh with
developing the ideal cloud platform for
the Next.js
infrastructure between Versel and
Nex.js. XJS and the whole suite of tools
that you can find in Next Forge. Uh
there's a really strong ecosystem of uh
pretty much everything you need to make
things happen in a client-based app. And
with these other parts, you get to
integrate your AI workflows right into
the client app. So, here's the beauty of
it. This set of tools actually works.
Now, the LLM still don't know how to
piece this all together, but that's what
I'm here to tell you. Maybe they can
start training on my repo and they'll
get there. But for now, you're going to
need to understand how to get this
implemented so you can guide your uh
your your vibe coding session in the
right way. Here's what the architecture
looks like or your user is going to
connect to your next.js app that is
going to be maybe checking the database.
Is work done? Is there something cached?
Do I need to do something new? We can
trigger a new workflow with an ingest
service sending an event to ingest.
Ingest is your orchestration layer that
manages your connection to Python
serverless functions where your AI
agents are running. The OpenAI agents
SDK is Python only right now. Uh but
that's okay because when you deploy your
Python functions to Verscell, Verscell
recognizes it as Python and
automatically hosts it for you. Those
Python functions can handle all your
inference talking to AI uh talking to
OpenAI uh to get the work done and
return results to the orchestration
layer which can again inform your your
front end your client app that the work
is done caching things in the database
as needed. So this is the essence of the
architecture but really I'm sure what
you want to see is the code. So, I built
an example app that uses AI agents to
create a newsletter, and I want to show
you how it works so that you can get a
sense of how all of these pieces work
together. So, let's take a look. Here's
the readme. Uh, this code, there's a
link to this code in the notes below.
Um, it's up on GitHub and, uh, you'll
get to explore it there. But, let me run
you through it so you can see what's
happening. So first of all, we're
highlighting that we are focusing on
serverless scalability, the ability to
support longunning jobs, so your agent
tasks don't just crash out or blow out
the uh time limits available for cloud
functions. That lets you really pay
attention to costs. You can adjust, you
can pay only for what you're actually
using and not keeping servers idle. Uh
all of these tools work together for a
really nice local developer experience.
And I'll get to show you a little bit of
that right now. And of course, you have
full type safety with Pyantic and Python
and and TypeScript across
Nex.js. So, how do you make it happen?
Well, once you've cloned this repo, all
you need to do is fire up three
terminals. One to run your Python
agents, one for Nex.js, and one for your
ingest dev server. This is a really nice
feature of this orchestration layer.
They give you a specific development
environment to manage it. So, let's see
what it looks like. We'll just go like
this. Fire up three terminals
here. Get Nex.js
going. And we get npm going. All right.
With those running, we can pop over and
take a look at our app.
Like I said earlier, we've got a read
me. Let's see what the app looks like.
Here it is up and running. This is the
homepage of my Nex.js
app. As you can see, running on
localhost 3000. Uh, and it provides a
place to enter some topics,
commaepparated list, as many topics as
you want, and it will attempt to
generate a newsletter that looks at
what's going on at the intersection of
those topics. Let's see what's going on
with AI engineering in Seattle. that's
where I'm based. And we can generate a
newsletter that will look up the latest
what's happening at the intersection of
these topics. So, we fire this off and
it creates a uh a page that's starting
to just pull against the database to see
if the database has the answers for us
yet. And we're using Versel's blob
storage for our data store. Can use
anything you like, but that's easy to
plug in. And uh in the meantime, we can
look at the ingest server and see it
running. Uh it looks like one of our
agent calls has already completed and it
got back some data. Uh and there's the
second agent call that's fired off. It
has saved it to the blob storage and did
a little finalization. So here you can
see our orchestration layer has broken
the whole task down into individual
steps. Each one of those steps can scale
up and down to the full length of what
Verscell allows for a cloud function to
run. Um, you can configure that for uh
up to a minute, I think, on the free
plan and even higher on pro plan. So,
you get plenty of bandwidth to play
around with individualized tasks when
you break it out that way. Uh, and then
overall as the page refreshes, it finds
the results in the database and presents
back to us our newsletter about what's
going on in Seattle and uh, and with AI
transformation
of engineering, all kinds of interesting
things about the a Seattle AI community
and uh, its own take on what we're
talking about with engineering.
All right. So there is the results of
our page and uh formatted very nicely as
a newsletter and we can go back and
generate more as needed. So let's take a
quick look through the code to get a
sense of how all of this works. So we
were looking at the readme and now we
can see the project structure here that
lays out everything in our app. Injest
itself has an endpoint that that cl that
the uh the orchestration server uh
connects to and shows us what's
happening. We get all the detail and
observability we need about what's going
on step by step in our codebase. Uh
because it's served right out of our
app. We have then the newsletter API
endpoints that ingest calls and that in
turn invokes the Python agents which are
over here at a top level API directory.
When Verscell finds this tople API
directory, it looks in and serves each
file as its own independent function. So
we get this as a cloud function. Uh
otherwise the workflow is defined in an
ingest folder that's within our source
code folder and we can have as many
different types of workflows as we want.
Each one triggering off of its own
event. So there you have it. Those are
the pieces that work together to make
this happen. Uh ultimately it's made up
once again of uh AI agents that are
powered by uh fast API. A really quick
and easy way to put them together,
right? All right. So, here's a look at
our AI agents. We have one that's doing
research. We have one that's formatting
and uh each of those has its own
endpoint in the fast AI app which can
spin it up really quickly. All Verscell
needs to know to get this going is this
one line of code at the bottom. It fires
it off as an independent file. And
you'll note here that this repo does not
even have a
Verscell.json config file. Verscell
automatically picks this up when you
have things structured this way. Um,
that's something I went in circles
around with the LLM on uh in a numerous
tries to get this get this whole stack
deployed
correctly. So, we've got the AI agent
and I'll show you too also here the
ingest workflow
uh which is found here in our ingest
functions. uh we define them here and I
really like to structure these so we
keep each step defined at the top and
each step is essentially just doing one
thing of calling out to a function that
we define below. Uh and of course in
JavaScript we can define those functions
later on in our code. Uh but this keeps
our overall highle orchestration very
clear what's going on. We're essentially
invoking each step and then doing some
type checking on it. Step one, call the
agent. Step two, format the newsletter
with another agent. And step three, save
this to our blob storage so the front
end can find it and and load it up. Uh,
so that's that's the that's what inest
provides as very nice lightweight
orchestration. One thing to remember is
that every
step.run will be invoked in order, but
code that's outside of step.run run that
you have uh for example up here may well
be executed multiple times as it comes
back to this function to figure out
exactly which step to run. So keep an
eye out for uh duplication of of
execution outside of those step
functions. But inside the step
functions, you can count on them to uh
reliably run in sequence and passing the
results to a variable that you can then
send into uh your next your next step.
All right. So here we have the results
of the initial research
agent. Uh after type checking, we pass
that into formatting our newsletter. We
take the results of that formatted
content after type checking and pass
that into saving to the
blob and uh and then of course that's
our final result which uh inest shows us
right there in that ingest dashboard. So
that's it. All of this fits within a
nextjs repository deployed to versel. It
fits together very well and allows for
all the scalability you would expect
from a serverless environment. all the
resilience that you need from a robust
orchestration layer and most
significantly all the agentic power that
you can get out of OpenAI with the
agents SDK. So this is my favorite
combination. Uh and uh it's working
well. It's working well. Uh it deploys
really nicely onto Verscell. You can see
here it is running on a Verscell URL.
Uh, and Verscell shows us the full logs
of how things get built. If you're
building this, here's a place to check
under the initial deployment. You can
see your API agents folder gets deployed
as a Python function. It's running
Python 3.12 in Verscell's current Python
environment. Uh, all laid clearly, laid
out clearly for you here. Full build
logs are available if you need to do any
troubleshooting, but ultimately it just
is as simple as actually running the
Verscell command right from your
terminal to deploy this code to
Verscell. I'll show you that too. We
have one more shell to pop
open. The Verscell CLI command lets you
sign in, connect to your environment
variables. You can actually pull down
your environment variables from
production and run them locally. For
this project, you need an OpenAI API
key. Of course, you need a Versel blob
storage token to use for storing your
data. Uh, and that's about it. Those two
environment variables are all you need
to get going. And you can fire off your
build process right
here. That gives you everything you need
to make it happen. So, that's a tour of
the app. That code is up on GitHub. Feel
free to check it out, make some
contributions. It's open sourced. It's
ready for you. Uh, I'd love to know what
you want to do with it. Uh, if you build
on top of it, take it and replace the
agents with with your own workflows. Uh,
then link back to it and we'll build a
whole section in there with examples of
what other people are doing with that
same basic structure. So, that's what
I've got for you. Thank you so much for
your time. I hope you find this helpful
and I can't wait to see what you do with
full stack agents in the cloud.